Hey go breasts my dear whatever whatever
she said welcome to Keith's teddy man
I've seen this game when I was a kid but
I never actually played it and I was
just remembered about and I'm like yes
oh yes indeed I've I haven't even played
it yet and it's already my favorite game
of all time so this game gets pretty
intense I don't know how I'm gonna
comment over this I will try as a story
like parappa the rapper which is just
the best the PlayStation 2 era man don't
even get me started
look at the graphics there has charm
it's a dog eating a doughnut oh you won
konzi been picking on you again it's
gonna chop me in half what's it get
tired man
when anti-tarnish oh dude
so cheesy Wow Wow
yeah I'll take it okay we're good baby
so there's the health bar between all of
us now she's gonna attack that wait till
me oh I'm still I'm not good at this
game all right
there we go
Wow yeah but you gotta man okay it's our
attack
yeah
[ __ ]
goddammit
it's like it's hard enough to play now I
have to talk over it yeah
I'll take it
what the [ __ ] is going on in the
background I can't keep up I literally
can't the [ __ ] is going on
how do I keep missing I don't understand
I'm trying so [ __ ] hard Jesus final
all right finish him
oh my god what the actual
yeah yeah
Wow
get out of man
wham bam bam pow
[ __ ] it
can I do it you let your captain
I missed the last note goddamn it so sad
it's still going yeah damn it nomads had
one chance to look cool I felt too many
anyway it doesn't matter okay I don't
know what just happened but stop see
I'll take it
there's a story going on I want to know
what's gonna happen what's the actual
[ __ ] is happening in this day it's a
crab boat me flying oh come out the
caravan give me guitar oh go Lily
okay there we go Stage two baby yes
it's the job turkey today man
what the [ __ ] am I doing wrong
oh my god oh my god what is happening
why do I miss that but its grace to my
family
yeah yeah that's it that's what I'm
talking about [ __ ] yeah
I tried I [ __ ] tried all right he's
almost dead prez we could do this we can
do this [ __ ] come on
oh [ __ ] men yes oh [ __ ] men I can't keep
oh my god I was amazing
oh this game is [ __ ] awesome why have
I not played it oh damn [ __ ] you man I I
take a see any day do you want more of
this leave a like and let me know in the
comments and I will see you until then
keep rockin on no one can see me I am
justice